the biggest criminal to ever enter our
White House takes the fifth amendment in
his Civil Trial not surprising at all I
wasn't surprised were you surprised if
you were surprised too boy you are not
paying attention you know it's really
funny because the last few days
on and on and on the media is really
trying to make this out to be a great
thing for them to get ratings around
Donald Trump here when they're saying oh
what are the ramifications for this it
seems like it seems like this is big
government and everyone is forgetting
that in New York that he was gonna he
did a deposition today and he pled the
fifth so he doesn't self-incriminate
himself the reason why he would do this
is because his business the Trump
organization his family business that
he's ran for decades is charged with
crimes we keep forgetting this his CFO
his partner and his business and his
business itself is charged with crime
times he's a [ __ ] criminal why is it
so unprecedented that a [ __ ] criminal
a career criminal who is whose business
is charged with crimes in the state of
New York and his CFO Alan weisselberg is
also charged with crimes in the state of
New York Tish James deposed him and he
pled the fifth so he dealt didn't
self-incriminate this morning I mean it
would be almost like someone who ran for
president and back in 2016 would say
only Mobsters take the fifth when you
have your staff taking the Fifth
Amendment taking the fifth so they're
not prosecuted I think it's disgraceful
if you're not guilty of a crime why do
you need immunity for pleading the Fifth
Amendment pleading the Fifth Amendment
taking the Fifth Amendment the fifth
amendment in the Fifth Amendment Fifth
Amendment Fifth Amendment Fifth
Amendment horrible you see the mob takes
off him if you're innocent why are you
taking the Fifth Amendment have you ever
ever seen anything so corrupt in your
life have you ever seen a greater
embarrassment to our country Fifth
Amendment Bob
we gotta see this idiot say these things
that and then he does them it's all
projection always every [ __ ] time but
why is the media so surprised and it's
so unprecedented and right Wingers are
so upset that the FBI would go raid his
home at Mar-A-Lago this is not
surprising it's not unprecedented it's
not it's unprecedented that you [ __ ]
morons still support this idiot you
[ __ ] morons put this bonehead in
office and then act like he was the
greatest thing since sliced bread after
one impeachment after two impeachments
after he [ __ ] incited a violent
Insurrection and tried to take away our
government and our democracy this is not
unprecedented this is [ __ ] When
someone tells that tell them to [ __ ] off
it is not unprecedented that we in this
country treat a [ __ ] career criminal
like a career criminal that is something
we should continue to do and we need
more of it